you know people tell you proudly in
America readings not for them there no
readings not for me proudly long I
that's famous fat well round is the only
place people take a an intense pride in
their ignorance it might not be the only
place but it's one of them they just
laugh in your face ago I don't know
anything about that if you start saying
something intelligent they'll laugh at
you I don't know anything about that big
smile on their face because they think
they've won and they have they've won
there there they've won because they
don't know and then one day you know it
all delights just go black anyway it
just all goes black the end produced by
Dick Wolf it's all over you know so it's
not that I'm like politically I think
Sanders is really interesting I thought
trouble is gonna be interesting I think
Trump's somewhat less interesting than I
think I think the response to Trump is
interesting because these [ __ ]
Psychopaths on the other side cannot
effectively counter him at all and it
just proves that they're as wantedly the
Democratic Party's just wanted ly
corrupt as anything and they're trying
to steal it from Bernie and they're
trying to give it to boo to judge
because he works for the CIA or whether
he knows it or not and he probably does
it's just what it is okay and watching
this in real time watching the biggest
human trafficking case with huge
political implications watching that
completely go away and get out of the
news cycle is [ __ ] fascinating
watching this guy get killed watching
that all be covered up watching them try
to steal the election from Bernie in
[ __ ] real time I don't care if you
like Bernie or not what's happening
right now is [ __ ] historic you're
watching the ruling class of this
country losing power and trying is
scratching desperately any way they can
to rest and put power back in the
control of the billionaire cartels of
Wall Street Hollywood big tack big
pharma all of these [ __ ] things these
elite me
organs of opinion whether it's a
Washington Post or MSNBC or the New York
Times they're all trying to diminish
Bernie's accomplishments they did it
with Trump they've been doing it well
you know soon as Trump got elected there
was a coordinated attack on him from
every which way not to say some of it
wasn't justified he's a shady guy but it
was over the top these things are kind
of invented this collusion rush and
narrative never played out in the amount
of the amount that it was hyped
you said that the president was an agent
of a foreign power for two years and
then turned around with oops I guess we
were wrong it's absurd and they're doing
the same thing to Bernie in the
primaries you have to realize that doing
the exact same thing they're throwing
everything they can at him whether you
[ __ ] think his economic policies are
reasonable or not understand the moment
historically that you're living in many
of you do not grasp it yet because
things are so good there's still waffle
sundaes and puppet shows
I don't know that that'll be around
forever and I know that when there's
still waffle sundaes and puppet shows I
like the former many of you like the
latter but because they're still waffle
sundaes and publishers nobody has fully
taken time to appreciate the time and
place in history you are in now we're
seeing the cracks of a civilization
become too big to hide and the fractures
are becoming too deep and too meaningful
to ignore and it's the national security
state it's big-money players and the
people in this country are turning on
the government they are turning on the
established order
they have been fed a diet of [ __ ]
and lies for very long [ __ ] time
we've seen horrible abuses of women
children human rights abuses all of the
[ __ ] coming to head in the last 24 to 48
months and people are flipping the [ __ ]
out people's minds of melton the q1 on
call
people that really can't handle how much
real [ __ ] is [ __ ] up so they've kind
of invented this subterranean war that
Trump is having with these deep state
people and he's gonna you know bring
justice to all of these people and
whatever all these people that they
think are involved and you know and
there's no real proof for that there's
no evidence for that other than
conjecture and and that's not to say
that there aren't slimy shady people in
Hollywood in Washington and we I've
talked about that as much as anyone on
this [ __ ] planet I mean maybe not as
much as anyone on the planet cuz I want
to have a little fun and laugh a little
bit - I just can't [ __ ] talk about
that every bucket minute but you know we
get how [ __ ] it is and I get the you
know people wanting there to be this war
happening I've never I've never not
wanted it to happen I hope it is
happening I just haven't seen any
evidence of it and if I don't see any
evidence of something then I turn into
Rachel Maddow sputtering on about
Russian BOTS and Putin like a lunatic
and I refuse to let my mind be melted
even though it's a mind melting time
it's a mind melting time Trump is the
president you know that's wild in and of
itself Alex Jones is one guy in Austin
Texas that had a news you know
organization one guy that became so
threatening rightly or wrongly whatever
you want to say and all the tech
companies kind of got together indie
platform to him and took all of his bit
you know he was kind of unperson -
whatever you want to say disappeared and
it's crazy time that you have one person
with that reach that becomes that much
of a threat to whoever that they got a
you know take quick action to get rid of
them and you might agree you might go
hey he's [ __ ] up things at Sandy Hook
blah blah blah none of this is we're not
immoral arguments about all these things
one of what I'm telling you is just sit
back and think about how inconceivable
any of this was even ten
years ago that these types of things
were happening because again this is the
result of the the independence of media
it's starting to become a real problem
for people in power it's becoming a real
devastating trend for them and they're
gonna have to do everything they can and
they're starting with apps and the apps
not working well the app doesn't work
the app doesn't tabulate the votes and
then they report that Pete named he came
in second and third and they barely
mentioned the Bernie won and then
they'll tar him and feather them and say
this about him and not about them and
they'll you know arrange it so or
hopefully they won't but they're gonna
try as hard as they can to get their boy
in the white house their gal whoever you
know the same reason Trump you know
dropped that big bomb and Syria soon as
he got antes playing the game it's just
what it is the mother of all bombs the
Moab
you know we're defeating Isis you know
if you still believe that I got eyes I
don't know what to tell you I got some
jewels to sell you I mean why Isis all
these things that don't exist that we
pretend we make them op which we trot
them out when we need them Isis yeah
yeah there are us Islamic state there's
horrible they're terrorists they're bad
bad boys and girls over there we gotta
go set him straight
we gotta go said I'm straight and then
we go do that and then you know six
months later they're back again because
I guess they're the most powerful
fighting force in the world cuz I
thought we were but somehow they evaded
us or they went underground and it came
back up and it's like you know what what
a fun little whack Amole situation we've
got going on there in the Middle East
and it'll truly never end and Bernie's
really not going to do much about it
either because he's been he's talked
about the military-industrial complex
and I respect that but it's just how do
you unwind that you just don't folks you
don't really unwind that and you you
people out there to think you can unwind
it understand you can unwind it but it's
not gonna be good it's gonna be bad it's
not and I'm not saying don't do it
because it's morally and imperative that
we don't do but understand the amount of
money that these people are making
they're gonna fight back it's gonna be a
fight and listen you might win you won't
but understand it's gonna be bad they're
gonna do bad things I'm not saying it's
not a worthwhile endeavor but understand
what's happening a lot of you have this
pie-in-the-sky
view of things that you things are just
gonna change peacefully and playfully
and everyone's gonna be alright now is
your turn it's not gonna happen dude if
these people are not going to give up
power without a tremendous fight they're
not gonna give up the money they're not
gonna give up control and you're not
taking it from them it's not gonna be
violence in the street
it's not gonna be had to fight it's not
gonna be a black backpack in your hat
and you're throwing an egg it's Gavin
McGinnis none of that matters to these
people they don't give a [ __ ] because
they have the police and the military
and all the technology and all the money
and all the resources and all the land
and all the corporations and all the
tack and the bubala what you have is
Twitter you have Twitter you got nine
online you mean now if we have some
massive demonstrations massive civil
disobedience if we have a guy like
Bernie Sanders maybe he's a
transformational figure maybe he's not I
don't know
I'm skeptical about how anybody but
understand what this [ __ ] is what it is
at its core who we are
stop forgetting who we are ray I was on
the phone ray today brought up a great
point who didn't people think we are out
there you know we gotta get back to wit
what hot get back this country is a scam
it ran out of steam about 50 years ago
it's been propped up by cheap credit and
Foreign Wars and it's gonna fall and
it's gonna be bad
not immediately and not you know but
it's coming it's coming
and those fat behemoths know down deep
it's coming that's why they all file
into the arena and watch the puppets
because maybe they're smarter than us
maybe they're actually the smart ones
maybe they just want the raw [ __ ]
form of what this really is why dress it
up with Pete Budaj heads and Amy
Klondike bar whatever her name is
why dress any of this [ __ ] up why not
just go back to it in its original form
furry puppets because that's what it is
Entertainment bread and circus spectacle
so maybe I'm the idiot that tries to
make sense of it and they're the people
that just file in and watch the puppets
you know because those puppets are
probably a hell of a lot funnier than
people to judge maybe they're not as
always they leave this broadcast with a
great hope for mankind
[Laughter]